we've heard for years that Will Smith
and Jada Smith have a little bit of a
difficult marriage this came to a climax
when during the Oscars Chris Rock made
an anod joke about Jada Smith and Will
Smith got up there and smacked him
across the face it was very very strange
but for years they've will and J Smith
have been open about uh cheating on each
other and you know Jada Smith had some
very young boyfriend and it just seems
rough but they said we're not going to
get divorced ever
bad bad marriage for life which was a
play on Bad Boys for life and well now
Jada Smith has revealed to the Today
show that she and will have been
separated for S
years why did the relationship
fracture oh why it fractured that that's
a lot of things and I think by the time
we got to 2016 we were just exhausted
with trying I think we were both kind of
still stuck in our fantasy of what we
thought the other person should be Jen
says she considered a legal divorce but
could never go through with it I made a
promise that there will never be a
reason for us to get a divorce we will
work through whatever and I just haven't
been able to break that
promise good that's good I know
everyone's going to attack J Smith
because she seems just absolutely awful
in most ways but I tell you that is a
really redeeming statement that she just
made she said even though we have this
terrible relationship and even though
it's Hollywood so everyone gets divorced
and even though we've been living
separate lives and even though we've
been cheating on each other and even
though we've been doing this and that
and the other
thing I can't bring myself to get a
divorce because I made a vow and it just
seems wrong and even me living in
Hollywood being a big lib doing all this
crazy stuff even me I know it's wrong
and I don't want to do it good good
follow that voice Arnold Schwarzenegger
as a self help but coming out he just
came out and explained that he doesn't
want to talk about the explosion of his
marriage anymore because that is the
biggest failure he's ever had he said I
blew up my
family no failure has ever felt worse
than that Darius Rucker from hoodie and
the Blowfish he he just split with his
wife after 20 years of marriage he said
you feel like a failure you try to
express those feelings and it's hard to
say and it's hard to put that on paper
you try to do it as real as you can I'm
not a big talk to you guy but I can sit
down and write a song about it that
stuff hurts you feel like a failure but
we're still a family a piece of paper is
not going to change that we're still a
family and that's all because Beth is
awesome she knows what's best for the
kids she's a great human
being
okay you see really big people here
really big successful lauded praised
people saying divorce is the biggest
failure I've ever had I in some cases
saying divorce is such an a scary
failure I I can't bring myself to do it
even though we're separated some people
saying I did get divorced and I'm rich
and I'm famous and I'm powerful and I'm
this and I'm that I was the governor of
California and it's the biggest failure
ever even huge stars are claiming that
the biggest failure they could possibly
have is divorce Jada Smith saying even
with our awful marriage I can't bring
myself to do it and and then hoodie and
the Blowfish over here Darius Rucker
makes an even more insightful point he
says we're still a family he says even
though we've been
divorced we're still a family it's we
got this piece of paper that says we're
divorced but we we're still involved in
each other's lives we still we can't
pull away from one another which is an
observation that some of us have been
making for years divorce is practically
speaking almost always impossible
especially when there's kids so you know
the church says the Christian view is
that divorce is not possible what God
has joined let no man
separate uh certain Christian
denominations accept divorce but the
vast majority do not and for the vast
majority of of the history of the church
divorce has not been recognized or
accepted in any way and obviously the
Catholic Church still holds to that
um even if you don't believe in God or
Christianity or religion or anything
like
that the point expressed perfectly by
the church that divorce is not a
possibility what God has joined no man
can separate is expressed by Darius
Rucker in this really practical way
where he says you know just practically
speaking we still got the kids we still
see each other we still talk we still
have to interact with one another so you
can't you actually just can't do it it's
not possible and I I hate to give
Hollywood some credit here but they
deserve a little bit of credit which is
there the people who seem most likely to
divorce these Hollywood
stars they're warning people about the
reality of that they're saying don't
fall into the same thing that I've
fallen into it's not pleasant it's not
even really possible Right Now go to
jus.com
nsyt everyone here at the office loves
the genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector you
might be asking what this product even
does well if you've got sunspots dark
spots discoloration or dry skin the
genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector will help
those blemishes disappear in front of
your very eyes Kimberly from Youngstown
Ohio says my appearance has improved so
much since using genus cell I love all
my genus cell products and my skin looks
younger now it's your turn to feel like
Kimberly but hurry this sale is ending
very soon take advantage of genus cell's
most popular package which includes the
Beloved dark spot corrector this package
also includes the genell classic under
eye treatment you will get all these
products for almost 70 70% off genus
cell is so confident in their products
that you can try them for yourself
completely risk-free if you don't see
immediate results you will get your
money back it's very simple go to Jus
cell.com nsyt start looking years even
decades younger tomorrow say goodbye to
dark and liver spots bags and puffiness
under the eyes crowfeet at Jus cell.com
letter y letter T jus.com
YT GTH paltro just revealed where she
stores her Oscar and I love
it and what a beautiful Academy Award my
door stop it works
perfectly I love it and it's a sort of a
teh he haha look we're filming this
little take on Gwyneth pelt's home and
oh my goodness outside she's she's got
her Oscar as a door stop oh yeah it's a
great door stop I'd love this this is a
really healthy attitude when it comes to
something like Fame there was a uh
famous uh journalist magazine editor and
Catholic priest who uh in his home he
kept all of his pictures with Statesmen
and prominent people in the bathroom and
friend of mine once asked this man why
why are they all in the bathroom he said
because that's exactly where the glories
of this world belong is in the bathroom
uh this is a healthy
attitude when it comes to something like
Fame
especially Hollywood which is so rotten
where nothing really is as it seems
where so much of of Hollywood is a
facade and just beneath the glitz and
the glamour you have Decay and you have
you know uh the decline you have the
collapse of families and you have people
selling their bodies to get parts and
you it's just pretend I mean the whole
place is just pretend and so when when
you're faced with something that is
pretend
what ephemeral really fleeting then
that's a good way to treat those glories
uh that would not be a healthy attitude
however when it comes to something that
really matters like family like honor
like dignity like piety like
sanctity then you would not want to
treat that as just something to be left
out in the rain to stop up your gate
outside or anything then you would want
it you would want to cherish that you
would want to treat it very well and one
of the big problems in the modern world
is we totally flip it so in the in the
modern world we treasure Fame and
notoriety and clicks on social media we
treasure that as our most dearly held
possession we would never leave that out
in the rain stopping up a door no we we
spend our efforts we spend our time we
spend our our love on that and we let
things like you know family honor
dignity
modesty uh we we we forget about that
stuff
you don't need to be a Hollywood store
to recognize this how many people
sacrific their family on the altar of
career or on the altar of professional
ambition or on the altar of fun on the
altar of Hedonism on the altar of
selfishness we do that all the time this
is real some people are going to look at
winth palra say she's totally crazy
she's being disrespectful to the academy
and to Hollywood by this top
professional achievement she just th no
that's where it belongs is out in the
garden it belongs out there stopping up
a
door we need to cherish the things that
are worth cherishing we need to uh keep
in proper perspective the things that
might seem glittery and pretty in this
world but will not last boy what a great
clip that was now hey hey hey hey hey
hey ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael N YouTube channel we'll see you
next time